analizamos los premios Nobel con más
Romero sala mar bienvenido un gusto
tenerla en el estudio como siempre Todas
las mañanas en directo América vamos a
desgranar un poco el premio Nobel de
física Marc que nos lleva a hablar de la
mecánica cuántica Buenos días Raúl Así
es Noel de física siempre es uno de los
que más atención se lleva incluso siendo
a veces uno de los más difíciles de
comprender redicine no como miramos el
mundo y por eso también genera tanta
expectación escuchemos el momento
la Real Academia sueca de ciencias ha
decidido esta mañana otorgar el premio
Nobel de física 2022 en partes iguales a
ala aspe de Francia John floser de
Estados Unidos y anton saleger de
Austria recibieron el premio por
experimentos con fotones entrelazados
que establecieron la violación de las
desigualdades de Bell y fueron Pioneros
en la ciencia de la información cuántica
la física cuántica Raúl le sabemos que
es difícil de comprender porque a veces
no se corresponde con lo que
experimentamos con nuestros sentidos y
eso lo hace muy contraintuitivo pero
básicamente estos tres premiados a lo
largo de su vida han hecho experimentos
que demuestran que así nuestros sentidos
nos llegan lo contrario la naturaleza si
responde a la física cuántica por eso se
los considera no Pioneros de esta
disciplina y además han desarrollado
Pues muchas técnicas y experimentos de
investigación alrededor de las
partículas entrelazadas luego entraremos
en más detalle abriendo las puertas a
una nueva era en las comunicaciones mar
antes de entrar en estos detalles que
hagamos una breve Introducción a lo que
es la mecánica cuántica una ABC no
porque para entender un poquito en qué
términos vamos a estar hablando y tener
claros los los conceptos la mecánica
cuántica parece cuando nos ponemos a
mirar a niveles atómicos o subatómicos y
vemos que las leyes de la física clásica
que entendíamos pues como el sol gira en
la galaxia como la tierra alrededor del
sol como la aceleración la masa no
aplican en realidad a estos niveles
atómicos de subatómicos partículas no
hace décadas que empezaron los primeros
postulados y de hecho sus caminos
desconcertaron al mismo Albert Einstein
no por ser tan alejados de lo que
normalmente en esos momentos se pensaba
repasemos algunos conceptos básicos por
ejemplo las partículas que recordemos es
esa parte de masa diminuta no que
conforman los átomos por ejemplo un
fotón o un electrón existen en un estado
de incertidumbre Tienen varias
cualidades al tiempo múltiples y no la
sabemos no sabemos Cuáles son hasta que
las observamos y el hecho de medirlas o
observarlas determina Entonces qué
calidad o qué valor tienen en esa
calidad Por ejemplo si son rojas blancas
a negras antes de mirarlas existen en
múltiples probabilidades de color otro
concepto es que se cree que la materia y
la onda son dos cosas distintas en la
física clásica no los fotones y la luz
por ejemplo el fotón es la materia la
luz es la onda En cambio la física
cuántica plantea que las partículas son
a la vez onda y a la vez materia no se
presentan de una forma u otra según de
nuevo las miramos o como las observamos
que experimento hagamos No eso Por
supuesto también habrá un mundo de
probabilidades de nuevo en el que la
materia puede técnicamente estar a la
vez en varios sitios hasta que la
medimos volvemos Entonces al Premio
Nobel que experimentos desarrollaron los
premiados marca precisamente atrás usted
están en este momento imágenes en vivo
que nos están llegando de uno del uso
premiados no Así estaremos atentos a
escuchar que dicen porque seguro es muy
interesante ver que tienen a decir al
respecto de la premiación no pero bueno
respecto a eso a estos experimentos cada
uno fue por su lado refinando
experimentos que había hecho el anterior
no el primero fue John closer que es el
estadounidense y el resto fueron
construyendo sobre sus experimentos algo
que también nos habla de la belleza no
colaborativa de la ciencia Entonces
vamos a un ejemplo de la misma
página web de la Premio Nobel que nos
daban para poder entender Cómo fueron no
tenemos una caja y dentro de una caja y
dos bolas una negra y una blanca que
suena pues lo que representarían las
partículas en este no sabemos Qué color
tienen hasta que nos salen de la caja
entonces uno pues ve que una bola la
recibió Blanca la otra la recibió negra
y ahí saben de qué color fue sin tener
la información desde antes porque
estaban ocultas por esta caja entonces
hay una pregunta de hecho que molestó a
los científicos durante décadas 10 si
realmente estas bolas ya eran negras o
blancas desde antes desde dentro de la
caja como veremos en el primer ejemplo o
si tenían un color indeterminado digamos
gris en este caso para facilitar el
ejemplo antes y fue al salir y al verlas
que recibieron esta cualidad de blanco o
de negro no entonces una de las por
ejemplo estas hipótesis planteadas era
que las bolas tenían unas variables
ocultas antes que no éramos capaces de
ver no habían unas cosas que ya
determinaban que la bola fuera Blanca o
fuera negra desde antes no sabíamos
cuáles eran por eso variables ocultas
pero que desde antes ya estaban diciendo
De qué color iban a ser las bolas
mientras que la mecánica cuántica
plantea lo opuesto no que tenían un
color indefinido y es el hecho de
observarlas que la cualidad de Blanca o
de negra entonces básicamente lo que han
logrado estos premiados es demostrar
mediante una serie de experimentos en la
vida real que es la segunda hipótesis la
de la mecánica cuántica la que opera en
la naturaleza lo hicieron en este caso
con fotones de luz que harían el papel
de las bolas y por lo tanto demuestran
que la naturaleza responde a estos
postulados y eso nos lleva a hablar amar
de las partículas entrelazadas exacto no
esto vemos no cuando una bola mostraba
una característica la otra era detrás y
más negra la otra es blanca no jugando
con el mismo ejemplo eso sucede con
muchísima más información con muchas más
características básicamente dos
partículas que pueden existir en un
estado compartido Y que cuando mides una
característica de una sabes esa
característica en la otra sin necesidad
de ir a medirla y además estando a
distancias separadas eso ya es
sorprendente pero es que además de estos
premiados experimentaron que pasaba si
estas par de partículas viajaba más
lejos y se encontraban con otras y en
este caso se vieron que absorbían sus
calidades somos capaces de transmitir
digamos toda esa probabilidad de
múltiples calidades existiendo a la vez
de una a la otra en algo que se llama
teletransportación cuántica no Y además
Pues aquí vemos últimamente para
terminar que si además estas partículas
chocan entre ellas y están entrelazadas
se entrelazan entre ellas haciendo que
en este caso la una y las cuatro
compartan cualidades sin haberse tocado
nunca abriendo posibilidades
inexploradas de pues transmisión de la
información a gran escala Muchísimas
gracias mar como siempre por toda la
información que Dios mío la vi muy
juiciosa estoy dando ahí antes de
hacernos esta exposición magistral
tuvimos que estudiar mucho así mar
Muchísimas gracias como siempre mañana
con más análisis no de lo que va a hacer
el próximo premio